before we get out of here there's an
article about people the overpopulation
is going to be concerned um going to be
fixed by metaverse children
this is a thing where people are going
to have children in the metaverse
because they're not actually there
they're not real and I and I wanted to
get get your I think anybody who
believes that yeah should absolutely
have a metaverse child instead of a
physical child that's right I think that
we should end
the DNA strand that believes that yes I
mean those there's those people that you
know there's that thing
where they're all trying to get in the
Mainframe yes and live forever yeah
please do please do please all of you
yeah please upload yourselves yeah
they've already started it with meta is
a place that they're creating right so
they can go to it and live forever right
and by the way when you get canceled now
yeah you just you can live in your home
and feel okay right but in meta it's
going to be
Purgatory it's going to be they'll
actually send you to hell what's
interesting is you could go to a
metaverse yeah they're going to make a
hell of it the idea of that of course
they are damning you well that every day
because when you're once you're in
metaverse once that really becomes
existence right you're gonna have to
defend yourself there you're gonna have
a great Point earn every day that you
belong that's a great Point all of this
mechanism of looking into everything
you've said and thought right is going
to be used to weigh where you belong in
the metaverse do you think that they're
really going to create a metaverse
without a hierarchy without a system of
you I don't know right and what happens
to you in that matter well you get a lot
you they put they have a room for the
folks there's not going to be a
metaverse without Justice no of course
not so then
that's what all of this is practice for
interesting all of this stuff that we're
that they are doing now right small
parts of people right they're they're
and maybe it's a sage-like thing they're
getting it all into the thing into the
Mainframe and we can let all that go how
beautiful that would that be and then
we're just left with people walking in
the streets don't we are actually using
their whole Personality yeah
um but no I I everybody should go see
you at your last show yes at Madison
Square Garden also I'm at Wembley Arena
Christ I'm at Wembley and this one I
need to sell tickets to they're not
buying them anything sell them in you
got free Wembley Arena yes in London
October 4th this coming [ __ ] Tuesday
that's amazing and uh uh the night
before I'm at the Hammersmith Apollo
that's sold out that's been sold out for
ages amazing Wembley there's still I
think 6 000 tickets available for
Wembley if you are one of six thousand
people in the UK you gotta go to the
store go to this show in Wembley what
are you doing I'm going to do something
shocking at that time he's going to do
something I'm trying to do something I'm
I don't want to Telegraph it of course
but I might commit suicide at that show
Wembley but still buy tickets to the
Garden think about the ad rev that you
will get on a picture of Louis CK
committing suicide yes think about that
yeah because we restricted but we
restrict the phones yes I mean we don't
put them in
I
just we tell them don't take it out but
during suicide is what I'm saying is
that if you get a picture yeah
you'll be one of the few because we are
stopping people so that'd be worth a lot
of money it's worth a lot of money
please come to Wembley Arena also I'm
coming to Milwaukee I'm coming to
Atlanta uh New Orleans I'm thinking of
places that haven't sold out yet uh
Nashville I'm playing the Grand Ole Opry
in Nashville no October November
December 14th and I'm in Pittsburgh at a
place coming to Pittsburgh and uh uh all
those [ __ ] all those [ __ ] places
and you can go on my website buy all
seven specials for five twenty five
dollars it's the best deal uh you can
buy my new movie Fourth of July yeah and
uh the series Louis that I made the best
it's not on anywhere but my website so
it's exclusive I got it exclusive they
took it off of Amazon and off of apple
and they gave it to me exclusively right
and the reason I asked him to do that
was so that I could set a price that
those people wouldn't have because you
have to always be the same price yes to
have like competitive parody whatever
right so you only pay 30 bucks you get
all five seasons and you can stream them
for the next five years Louis CK
.com go to my website otherwise I can't
do this anymore stream of income except
my own industry now get Louis ck.com buy
all the [ __ ] give go give them the money
now yeah thank you all right thank you
sure man I appreciate it it was fun